you used a word a couple times and i
just want to revisit that
you use the word enemy multiple times
for china uh i assume
you obviously are very careful with your
words are they a full-on
enemy of the united states is that
something you're very comfortable to use
well i mean here's the deal if if
somebody says
they're your enemy like they say it like
america is our enemy and we want to
destroy america
yeah like north korea says that's open
like if you
if you if you if somebody comes up to
you say i'm going to i'm going to kill
you
now do you say that's a that's a friend
right no i don't think anyone's
establishing it
but i mean but but i mean this is the
thing this is a crazy thing is
this is what they say all the time and
then you're saying that
i mean she the chinese communist party i
mean this is what they believe
how long have they been using that
rhetoric from the beginning
beginning of what she's administration
no from the beginning of the chinese
communist party
oh wow so why why did trump say i get a
lot of tr
i get along so well was she was it was
it sort of an
act what was that really so i mean so
there's
there's there's two things here um one
is
you know how what strategy were
were you know taking with regard to
china that's one thing
the other is you know if you have a
confrontation
with another country that has nuclear
weapons and you don't establish some
kind of communication dialogue
that could be very dangerous so cold war
russia days basically
exactly and i think the the the one
thing i actually agreed with
and the president it doesn't matter who
it is you need to remain you need to
maintain an open dialogue
he got criticized for talking to kim
jong-un you got to talk to
these people yeah even though you uh you
are
executing a strategy to
you stop what they're doing you know you
have
what's your which map do you have it's
you know is essentially you don't make
peace with your friends and your peace
with your enemies essentially no no no
you have
like okay say what happens we you know
we get into
crisis confrontation then becomes the
military
now you can't talk and and now we both
have nuclear weapons
that's not a good recipe in fact we
worked really hard
with the soviets to make sure that we
had this connection we had a red phone
between
moscow and washington dc to ensure that
hey
we want to make sure that this doesn't
escalate into full-blown conflict
because it is
the world's over that's why i know
there's a we're gonna transition here
simplifying things scale of one to ten
uh ten being like full-on nuclear war
one being
peace switzerland what have you how bad
were things during the cold war in the
you know 5060s with russia
one through ten and how bad are things
in that same scope with china today
well so there's two parts to that
there's the military uh
say confrontation i would say that was
you know
not could be you know at some times a 10
but
are approaching a 10 with russia with
with uh with the soviet union
i would say um but economically we were
killing them we were kicking their ass
and so
what's going on today is you know the
military's been dialed down quite a bit
but economically china's kicking our ass
and they're kicking our ass
because they've gotten wall street and
corporate america to basically
do what they want which by the way did
not happen during the cold war because
we had something called cocom cocom
prevented
the uh interaction between our business
community and the soviets
i want to show you something you know a
lot of time when you see he seems very
calm stoic like composure he has that
smile
this is a wonderful loving speech that
he gave uh uh
just like just a month ago not even a
month ago ten days ago
if you go lower at their hundred year
celebration go up a little bit you went
way
too low okay where he says social
socialism is good some volumes keep
going up kind of
okay uh there it is right there if you
make a little bit bigger kai where says
socialism is good
so he says beijing celebrates uh uh uh
celebrations began with a patriotic
showing uh
10 in men's square as helicopters and
fighters fighter jets flew overhead
hundreds of school children party
members and frontline healthcare
workers sang songs like socialism is
good and without the chinese communist
party
there would be no new china but the
centerpiece of the celebration was a
theory fiery speech given by communist
party
chairman xi jinping and here's what he
said the chinese people will never allow
any foreign forces
to bully oppress or enslave us anyone
who dares will have their heads
cracked and their blood will flow before
the streets
before the steel great wall built with
the flesh and blood of 1.4 billion
chinese people let me read that to you
one more time
anyone who dares will have their heads
cracked you know who talks like that
trump send me the bull talks like that
exactly exactly
since we will have your skull cracked
your head cracked
that's that's who your enemy is adam if
you're wondering i just wanted to
clarify for you
that's that's why they say keep
continuing yeah so if you continue
reading a little bit more to help adam
here
folks let's go a little lower kai
how winning the michael johnson party
spend more than an hour laying the
comments part of the channel
no he's wearing a mouse suit in front of
a picture a giant picture of him
telling you yeah it's all the way at the
top so the communist party of china and
the chinese people with their bravery
and tenacity solemnly proclaim to the
world that with the that the chinese
people are not only good at taking down
the old world
but also good at building a new one only
socialism can save china
and only socialism with chinese
characteristics can develop
china you know what's crazy here's
here's what i was uh talking about with
a group in aruba just four days ago
i said the pr and i want to hear your
thoughts on this i said uh
how many times have you and your wife
gone to an argument how many times have
you and your wife come to an argument
mine i can tell you my thousands
hundreds
it's a lot of our lives okay now i want
you to think about this take the top ten
arguments you guys had
okay i'm gonna take my top ten arguments
now let's make it make
that whether it was a 30-minute fight or
one hour one hour and a half
we put that on a facebook live okay and
everybody
sees that fight visually go to that
fight right
if i see your top 10 fights between you
and your wife
if somebody sees the top 10 fights
between me and my wife how much
leverage does the enemy have to help get
us closer to a divorce than help us stay
married
how much more leverage do they have
america is the left wing and the right
one call one the husband the other the
wife whatever it may be right
left wing would be wife right one would
be husband let's just say because left
would be like let's
spend money right is like let's save
money this takes a lot of work gas on
the brakes and the car
accident breaks whatever you want to
call it right two sides of the bird
the left wing and the right wings the
last top 100 biggest fights the world's
watching china sat there watching this
saying look at these
idiots so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye